Let's make the crispiest German potato pancakes,
also known as cutoffe puffa.
I used to have these all the time growing up,
especially in the winter time,
and they're way better than any hash brown is.
So I start off by grating some potatoes
and make sure to squeeze out all the liquid,
set that aside
and put my potatoes in a bowl with some grated up onion,
nutmeg, some eggs,
and give that really good mix.
Then I take my bowl with the potato water
and make sure to drain all that water off
and keep the starch at the bottom,
which I add to my potatoes alongside some baking powder,
just to make it a little bit more crispy.
Then these need to be eaten with apple sauce,
nothing else.
So I started making my apple sauce
by cutting up some honey crisp apples
and adding them to my pot with some water
and whatever sweetener you want.
I use some maple syrup.
Once they're really soft,
I blend them up
and there you go,
you have your apple sauce.
I formed the grated potatoes into little patties,
fried them off,
and then serve them alongside that warm apple sauce.
And these were so, so good.